hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video wie
heute ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut wir
befinden uns heute wieder um ein extrem
nice ist wirklich sehr also ich bin
ultra gespannt ich bin auf jeden fall
deutlich gespannt hat es bei den laptops
ihr werdet euch erinnern an die dies
gesehen haben ich habe zehn laptops aus
einem restposten lager in polen bestellt
und die das ausgepackt wenn ihr das
video noch nicht gesehen objects auf
jeden fall ab ich habe ja schon gesagt
dass ich auch zehn smartphones bestellt
hat die smartphones haben insgesamt 250
euro kostet alles restposten smartphones
ich erwarte jetzt nicht die krasseste
ware ist ja klar aber mir wurde
versprochen es kann von allen marken was
dabei sind das heißt samsung apple
huawei wie sony lg was gibt es noch
alles möglich und ja hier haben wir auch
schon das paket ist natürlich ein
bisschen kleiner als das letzte weg auch
nicht so viel ich würd mal schätzen hast
du 67 kilo vielleicht eigentlich stand
in der anzeige die kommen aus spanien
oder die sind in spanien gemeldet ich
sehe jetzt aber hier die kommen aus
münzenberg wo auch immer das in
deutschland liegt das paket war extrem
schnell da eigentlich ist das hier auch
viel mehr so ein testpaket also für
leute die dort wirklich 1000 smartphones
bestellen wollen dass die einmal jede
schauen können was sie denn so ungefähr
haben ich habe euch ja auch sicherlich
hier das eine oder andere foto von dem
angebot eingeblendet ach so bevor wir
weiter machen es gibt natürlich noch
eine extrem vierte verlosung heute in
diesem video wie in jedem video was im
dezember erscheinen wird ich habe ja
ultra viel gekauft dafür gehen wir mal
kurz rüber ins wohnzimmer da stehen
nämlich die ganzen geschenke kommt man
mit ok was sehen wir heute leute hinter
mir ist die wunderschöne
ja ja alles möglich dabei eigentlich
wollte ich heute saugroboter raushauen
von ex die haben mir drei zur verfügung
gestellt genauso wie den damen megageil
teil der brauchte wirklich gar nichts
mehr selber putzen aber ich würde sagen
weil es viel besser zum video passt es
geht heute um smartphones nehmen wir
einfach mal hier das iphone 8 das iphone
12 haben wir auch noch das wird
irgendwann später rauskommen einfach den
kanal abonnieren und so viele kommentare
schreiben wir bock habe das wird
irgendwann einfach ein kommentar
ausgewählt und angepinnt also schon
unbedingt wappen zu sein ob er nicht
vielleicht angeführt wurde sonst gibt es
glaube ich auch eine benachrichtung ich
weiß nicht genau da muss man ja sagen
passt vielmehr zum thema wir verlosen
heute hier das iphone 8 128 gigabyte
noch nie benutzt absolut neu ich habe
schon einmal aufgemacht für dieses video
halt aber extrem geil die dinger sind
auch noch 400 euro wert also das ist
glaube ich sehr neid eigentlich wollte
ich ja heute den saugroboter verlosen
von ex ultra geiles teil habe ich selber
wie gesagt im wert von 800 euro den
verlosen wir auch allerdings heute abend
im livestream auf alex v und 20 uhr
geht's los gehen kommt auf jeden fall
vorbei ich meine habt ja eh nix zu tun
und am ende des streams wird dann noch
der saugroboter irgendein verlost okay
jetzt wird wir uns aber hier wieder
diesem paket ich bin so gespannt
natürlich werde ich auch wieder
versuchen die ware zu geld machen wie
bei den laptops sechs der neuen laptops
die ich verkaufen wollte habe ich auch
dann verkauft die gegen ultra schnell
weg drei sind auch da da könnt ihr auf
jeden fall bei instagram schauen ich
werde euch immer die seit 1
worüber die ganze ware dann auch
verkauft wird wenn sich ein zuschauer
von euch dafür interessiert das gleiche
machen wir dann natürlich auch mit den
smartphones falls ihr wahre dabei ist
die man verkaufen kann
ich werde auch wieder schätzen wie viel
gewinnen man hier mitmachen kann also in
diesem video
ich hoffe einfach mal ich hab glück
hätte ich weiß es nicht eigentlich ist
es ein bisschen schade die ganzen
smartphones kommen auf jeden fall nicht
in der originalverpackung schaut mal wie
das paket aussieht hat er hier bitte
nichts raus fallen ihr könnt das ja
sehen hier sind die ganzen smartphones
eingewickelt in diese luftpolsterfolie
und hier darum herum liegen die ganzen
ladekabel das ist natürlich ein bisschen
schade weil ich habe gehofft die sind in
der ursprünglichen originalverpackung
aber es sind alle smartphones und dann
muss ja eigentlich was an wert dabei
sein wir schauen uns hier noch ganz
gewiss einmal das angebot an restposten
smartphone von top-marken bis 6 zoll
apple iphone galaxy lumia experience
nokia lg huawei usw alles dabei so kann
das dann anscheinend aussehen bei mir
saß ein bisschen anders aus und hier
haben wir dann samsung galaxy s vier
minister james 5 kein plan apple iphone
5 s samsung also an sich ganz neues wir
starten einfach mal mit dem ersten gerät
das haben wir denn hier ein windows
phone i glaub ich ja ein nokia windows
phone keine ahnung was das für 1 hat
hier unten auch schon kratzer aber sonst
ist das eigentlich in einem guten
zustand also ich denke das kann ich für
maximal 30 euro verkaufen mehr wird das
nicht mehr wert sein wobei wir werdens
abdecken ich lege die ganzen smartphones
einfach mal hier zur seite als nächstes
machen wir mal hier mit weiter euro
das ist das ist ein ganz altes gerät ach
du scheiße man also hier haben wir ein
samsung hier unten ist auch schon
einiges kaputtgegangen ich glaube dieses
gerät ist sicherlich schon über 50 mal
hin geklatscht und gehört irgendeinem
bauarbeiter so wie das aussieht geht
euch mal hier oben da fehlt das komplett
also das kann ich eigentlich komplett in
müll schmeißen vielleicht noch von
irgendeinem zehn euro für die ressourcen
darin verbaut sind kein plan
wir legen das auch einfach mal zur seite
da war das windows phone auf jeden fall
schon ein bißchen besser weitergeht
es kann ja weiter geht es hier mit schon
wieder ein samsung handy wieder das
gleiche haben wir nochmal das gleiche
ist allerdings diesmal nimmt deutlich
deutlich besseren zustand was ich total
verrückt finde das kenne ich gar nicht
mehr da bin ich noch zu jung für du
kannst das an scheint hier hinten so
drehen und dann ist es gesperrt und dann
kannst du auch so wieder entsperren
tschuldigung ich versuche das mal an zu
machen
vielleicht haben wir ja da sei ja noch
akku drauf ob samsung galaxy kammer 2
das sagt mir gar nichts mein zweites
smartphone das ich je bekommen habe
waren ein samsung galaxy s vier mini
deswegen erinnert mich das gerade krass
daran wie das halt so hoch fällt das war
bei meinem genauso aus meine das habe
ich so mit 15 bekommen also es ist schon
gut sieben jahre her ja mal und dann mit
diesem bild zum entsperren über den
bildschirm wischen
okay gut wir fangen als erster
wieder entschuldigung weiter geht es mit
dem nächsten gerät also bis jetzt
okay ein lg ich will mal sagen das gerät
ist von all diesen vieren im besten
zustand wir können es auch mal an machen
auch hier interessiert nicht was das
finden ist lte steht hier nicht bei aber
ich denke mal auch hierfür werde ich
nicht mehr als 20 euro bekommen wenn
überhaupt irgendjemand auch so ein handy
haben möchte jetzt haben wir hier auf
jeden fall ein gerät was ein bisschen
größer ist als das ist ziemlich groß das
sieht schon ein bisschen interessanter
auch hier haben wir einen microsoft
handy microsoft welches das genau ist
weiß ich nicht wir machen es mal an also
das ist bis jetzt auf jeden fall das
beste gerät ich denke mal vielleicht
habe ich hier glück wie gesagt ich werde
gleich alle handys googeln und dann mal
so einen preis kalkulieren für was man
die verkaufen kann ich denke auch mal
das ist das neueste von den geräten mit
abstand bis jetzt willkommen zurück
jetzt hier nur noch wenige einstellungen
wir warten weiter jetzt werden wir apps
installiert alter das dauert noch ein
bisschen
wir ziehen einfach mal das nächste handy
raus auch wieder an microsoft handy ist
das das gleiche doch ein und dasselbe
gerät einmal hier in orange einmal hier
in schwarz erreichte aber nicht dass
hier an mache deswegen lege ich das
einfach mal wieder zur seite
und weiter geht es mit dem nächsten also
einiges haben wir hier noch selbst wenn
ich nur ein iphone 4 ziehen würde wäre
das schon leid weil das kann man auf
jeden fall in deutschland soweit ich
weiss noch für 60 oder 70 euro verkaufen
und vielleicht kriege ich für diese
dinger hier auch noch 50 euro ok weiter
gehts ja hier haben wir ein so dass sie
wieder alt aus ach du scheiße ist das
zum schieben ein genug hier ja aber hall
alter das ist ja nicht mein smartphone
oder obwohl vielleicht wer erinnert sich
noch an die zeit als diese handys total
im kombi diese blackberry teile alter es
gab wirklich eine zeit da warst du der
king wird so blackberry-handys die unten
dann noch so eine fette tastatur hatten
ja gut auch hier denke ich das wird mir
nicht mehr viel geld einbringen aber wir
gucken es natürlich trotzdem nach links
zur seite weiter geht's okay hier haben
wir wieder ein lg allerdings ein anderes
als dieses gerät ja dieses hier würde
ich mal etwas neuer einstufen
ach guck mal hier kann man sogar noch
eine folie das ist das sieht echt
unbenutzt aus ich glaube das ist absolut
in einem guten zustand also wenn
irgendwer von euch die 1000 jetzt schon
sagt ich brauche
dieses handy oder dieses handy dann
checkt bitte die seite ab und schreibt
mir einfach ich mache gute preis aber
bitte nur kontaktieren wenn die
ernsthaft interessiert seid weil ich
habe da auch schon mit einigen
geschrieben die glaube ich nur mit mir
reden wollten oder so hier haben wir
schon wieder diesen samsung klotz also
bei den laptops war ich mir direkt
sicher da kann ich auf jeden fall 56 700
euro gewinn machen hier habe ich
wahrscheinlich jetzt vor 150 euro bis
jetzt auf jeden fall er in sand gesetzt
aber wir werden sehen
okay hier haben wir schon wieder ein lg
hier hätten wir das schon mal einen spaß
das hier ist jetzt in weiß okay lass
dich mal so da liegen und ich glaube er
hat zu guter letzt ein sony ericsson
sony ericsson xperia die dinger also 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 entfernen dies sogar
ja was soll ich dazu sagen ich werde das
jetzt alles mal zusammenrechnen und wir
sehen uns dann sofort wieder
ich ahne aber böses ich glaube ich habe
dicken verlust gemacht bis gleich leute
also ich bin ein bisschen also ich bin
schon enttäuscht leider ich muss aber
auch sagen ich habe mir gerade noch mal
das angebot von dem angeschaut und vor
allem mit den bildern ist es wirklich
also ich hab wirklich nur scheiße
bekommt natürlich kann ich jetzt für die
knapp 300 euro die ich dafür bezahlt
haben jetzt auch nichts gast erwarten
aber ich meine das sind wirklich alles
nur absolute schrott annecy fast nichts
mehr wert sind und so das eine oder
andere was man dann vielleicht noch für
ein bisschen mehr verkaufen hätte ja
vielleicht auch mal dabei sein können
vor allem weil auf den fotos die da drin
hat auch deutlich bessere handys dabei
sind aber gut ich habe das jetzt alles
mal zusammengerechnet habe immer den
günstigsten wert genommen den ich
irgendwo gefunden habt und wenn es gut
läuft und nicht alles verkauft bekomme
lande ich bei maximal 240 euro das heißt
ungefähr 60 euro verlost 50 euro verlust
wenn irgendwer von euch irgendwie alle
handys haben will schreibt mir unbedingt
weil ich kann damit leider nichts
anfangen dann kann man natürlich
enterprise waren aber für mich hat sich
das ganze absolut nicht gelohnt die
laptops waren viel viel besser
ihr könnt man den kommentare schreiben
was für restposten noch kaufen da gibt
es alles möglich da gibt es von aldi
lidl es gibt konsolen ware es gibt
electronic restposten usw
also ich hab megawatt noch weiter
einzukaufen und ja mach beim gewinnspiel
mit wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder gibt
es das nächste geile video ich hoffe es
hat euch trotzdem gefallen und die hat
ein bisschen spannung dabei das war es
von mir
haut rein